or vendredi dernier donc orelsan a
remporté trois victoires de la musique
ça a été l'artiste plus récompensées et
on va vous dire ce qu'elle dit cette
pétition je vous le dis on va reprendre
les extraits de la part voilà d'une
chanson le titre qui s'appelait sale
[ __ ] en 2006 voulaient parole avait fait
polémique à cause de ses paroles
violentes et misogyne
vous allez nous dire ce que vous en
pensez et s'il faut lui retirer ses 3
victoires regarde trois victoires celui
ou celle qui dorénavant devra adapter à
mon avis son mode de marchands 3 pas à
celle ci 3 pas à cette fille est basique
orelsan montréal
alors celui ou celle qui va devoir faire
un peu de place sur sa cheminée et
orelsan la pétition
celui ou celle qui va devoir prendre
peut-être un peu de recul après toute
cette folie et cet amour et orelsan
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup j'ai pu de plus de
remerciement j'ai plus rien alors donc
orelsan donc il ya une pétition qui
tourne je vous le dis annulation des
prix du rappeur orelsan aux victoires de
la musique
et aujourd'hui cette pétition prend de
l'ampleur les paroles de cette chanson
va vous les rappeler je vais animer
jusqu'à ce qu'elles soient couchés et
qu'elle voit des clochettes mais ferme
ta gueule ouf tu vas te faire marie
trintigner ça c'était la phrase qui avec
sa maman exactement et c'est ça c'est la
part au ccc la voilà le truc qui a fait
le plus réagir
gilles verdez ou est-ce qu'il faut lui
enlever ses victoires oui je vous dis
franchement vous alors oui ces onze ans
après quand j'ai regardé la cérémonie
oui j'ai été choqué d'accord corel ça
mais trois victoires au moins ça mérite
débat on peut pas se racheter une
virginité comme ça en effaçant d'un
trait de plume le passé il a un passé
compliqué je ne suis pas d'accord qui
soit considéré comme le meilleur
musicien de l'année en france nous ne
rien demander ne faisait pas lui qui a
demandé à participer c'est pas lui qui a
demandé un mais qu'on lui attribue une
série d'accords de lui lui il ya une
chose
il a effectivement été poursuivis en
justice sa vocation à la discrimination
à la haine et à la violence
il a été pour un album donc de 2009 il a
été relaxé en 2016 et à plusieurs
reprises il s'est excusé en disant
attention ne confondez pas fiction et
réalité dans en l'occurrence dans ce
clip là je me moque d'un type bourré qui
dit n'importe quoi que lorsqu'il faut
lui enlever ce victor on est à plusieurs
reprises là il a même il avait même dit
que depuis ils ne mettaient pas ces deux
chansons dans son album qui ne les
mettait pas dans ses concerts alors
qu'il a quand même fait plusieurs villes
allemandes ne semble pas